[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler aymeric
guise et secrétaire général adjoint du
think tank le millénaire à bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau en
direct stéphane le rudulier porte parole
d'eric ciotti merci d'être avec nous ce
soir également en direct pour les
spécialistes dont benjamin morel docteur
en sciences politiques bonsoir benjamin
morel et puis nous rejoindra dans
quelques minutes votre nouvel adversaire
amical certes l'adversaire tout de même
pour quelques jours jean philippe pas du
coin clément porte parole de valérie
pécresse bonsoir et merci d'être là à
tous alors c'est un petit peu quand même
la surprise du jour on imagine que vous
êtes un homme heureux ce soir eric
relier le député a l'air donc des êtres
maritime qui s'est qualifié avec valérie
pécresse pour le second tour de la
primaire je vous propose tout d'abord de
l'écouter
j'ai voulu placer cette campagne sous le
signe de la vérité de la vérité sur la
situation
d'un pays en voie de déclassement de
déclin sur la clarté des alliances
jamais d'alliance hier aujourd'hui et
demain avec le maquereau 10 mhz et puis
sur le courage d'un vrai projet de
rupture eh bien je crois que cette
vérité cette clarté ce courage
ont
mobilisé ont mobilisé le soutien de nos
militants alors que j'étais loin très
loin même
d'être favori et que pendant des
semaines
les commentateurs que vous êtes m'avait
ranger dans la seconde catégorie des
candidats en formant un petit peu de
rancune stéphane de le rue de vienne ont
pas eric à eric c'est lui
c'est vrai qu'il a déjoué tous les
pronostics aujourd'hui eric ciotti on
l'a qualifié souvent de droite dure ça
veut dire quoi c'est le retour de la
droite forte au sein des dlr non je
pense que c'est le candidat qui a
véritablement le mieux parler aux
militants par rapport à ses convictions
et la sincérité de son engagement et à
respecter en fait l'adn qui était en
fait celui du rpr de l'époque des années
90 il en faisait déjà allusion à bon
nombre de reprises dans le cas de ces
réunions publiques et ça ça récompense
aussi la fidélité d'eric ciotti à son à
son parti quarante années de
militantisme mais je pense que les
militants lui ont dû comme il se devait
c'est ce qui a péché chez xavier
bertrand son infidélité valérie pécresse
chacun a fait la même chose chacun
tirera les conclusions qu'ils vont en
tirer effectivement v rik ciotti quel
que soit d'ailleurs l'état de notre
parti politique dans des soirs de
victoire comme dans des soirs de défaite
était toujours toujours aux côtés des
dirigeants de sa famille pour essayer de
relever le flambeau et et de reprendre
le combat idéologique pour faire gagner
nos idées et je pense que c'est grâce à
cela et également grâce à la force de
ses convictions et à la sincérité de son
engagement le savez les débats les
quatre débats le premier débat a été une
révélation pour un bon nombre d'entre
nous par rapport à l'engagement des deux
d'eric ciotti avait pas de faux semblant
il n'y avait pas de non-dits ni
d'imprécisions dans son projet tout
était dit
oui mais même il y avait une clarté dont
diagnostic et puis comme il le dit dans
son propre programme et c'est cette
question de fameux gant remplacement
qu'avait été posée à l'époque par une de
vos homologues il y a répondu ce n'est
pas un problème de vocabulaire s'il
fallait dire grand remplacement disons
le mais voilà mes solutions mais je
pense que ça a été appréciée au niveau
des militants
benjamin morel en attendant les perdants
ont rallié
mary pécresse xavier bertrand michel
barnier philippe juvin ils ont fait le
choix de rejoindre la candidate selon
eux la mieux placée pour l'emporter
ciotti se retrouve un petit peu seul
contre tous c'est un vote utile qui se
profile celle lr selon vous
c'est pas tout à fait évident c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui vous avez un
excellent tic est probablement beaucoup
plus à l'image d'un point de vue
idéologique la base des militants à la
base des adhérents air et donc il peut y
avoir un choix de la raison dans un
choix valérie pécresse si vous prenez
les enquêtes d'opinion en vue de la
présidentielle il peut y avoir un choix
du coeur pour une grande partie d'entre
eux notamment ceux qui ont voté michel
barnier vers eric ciotti la question
c'est est ce que le choix de la raison
est aussi déterminante parce que lorsque
vous regardez aujourd'hui les enquêtes
même si vous avez une avance pour
valérie pécresse eh bien elle n'est pas
non plus tout à fait écrasante par
ailleurs et bien vous avez un autre
candidat qui a utilisé à foison cet
argument des bons sondages dans les
enquêtes d'opinion il était bien devant
le palais crès s'est exilé bertrand donc
les pas évident que là-dessus ce soit
l'argument le plus marquant en revanche
et les pécresse a un avantage certain
sur aix lotis en termes de soutien de la
structure du parti à voir si on a de
nouveaux cadres qui se rallient or les
candidats eric ciotti il mais pour
l'instant on a quand même je dirais des
des barons des structures du parti qui
penche plutôt du côté de valérie
pécresse qu'eric ciotti et ça évidemment
cette donne avery pécresse un avantage
certain aymeric baisser votre film tant
qu'art et d'inspiration gaulliste et
réformatrices selon vous lequel des deux
candidats incarnent le mieux ce fameux
héritage le général de gaulle que tout
le monde s'arrache un petit peu
aimerait bien s'arracher tout le monde
se l'arrachent en effet nous les études
que nous avons menées depuis maintenant
plus d'un mois montré une tendance était
plutôt celle de valérie pécresse et dans
le même temps on a aussi vu l'émergence
la candidature d'erik satie qui est
monté manière très impressionnante sur
les dernières semaines et finalement ce
résultat même s'il est très serré pour
les quatre candidats qui arrive en tête
il confirme deux choses 1 ce que c'est
finalement les candidats qui ont été le
plus proche du barycentre et de logique
du parti qui s'en sont mieux sorties et
un deuxième élément c'est la performance
lors des débats télévisés qui ont une
importance croissante au fil des
semaines et finalement il ya une
certaine logique que ce soient ces deux
candidats qui se retrouve au second tour
ce soir sont le plus au centre du parti
d'un point de vue idéologique au
barycentre du parti et s'ils ont le
mieux réussi leur prestation
télévisuelle alors on va les retrouver
jean philippe dugoin clément qui est
avec nous en direct merci de nous
rejoindre vous êtes donc le porte parole
de valérie pécresse merci d'être avec
nous ce soir eric ciotti 10 de sa
désormais adversaire elle a un
positionnement trop centriste trop
proche du maquereau nisme elle ne
parviendra pas à battre à emmanuel
macron nous ne gagnerons pas en étant
sociaux démocrates mais en étant
réformateur que répondez vous à cela
bonsoir oui la départ parole l'un des
orateurs
non je crois de glace et il ya la
caricature se comporte avec valérie
c'est un projet de rupture extrêmement
fort au même titre que ce qu'elle a fait
ce que nous avons fait avec est longue
de france on est sur un projet de
rupture très fort par rapport à ce que
fait le gouvernement à l'heure actuelle
est d'ailleurs y'a aucun point commun on
est sur une page qui va se tourner et il
page qui va se tourner sur la base d'un
projet travail et porter construit
depuis des mois maintenant art gallery
il ya eu un travail le font absolument
colossal qui a été fait est une
d'ailleurs moi je note que si elle a pu
performer comme elle l'a fait sur les
sodas sur les départs aller au-delà de
ce qu'imaginer les sondages parce que
quand valérie aux proches et chaque
ordinateur au mois de juillet comme eric
ciotti d'ailleurs peu de gens
attendaient cette finale et bien c'est
parce que l'un comme l'autre ont eu des
programmes qui sont construits on non a
bâti sur du sable blanc bâti sur des
éléments solides et sur un projet de
rupture par rapport à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui alors le sujet il sera bien
évidemment de parvenir à rassembler
rassembler largement à rassembler au
delà de sa famille politique stricto
sensu et je pense que avec des tresses
aura la capacité à le faire ses fans
heureux de lier c'est vrai que eric
ciotti sur toi un type de sol on dise et
contre tous tout le monde appelle à
voter pour valérie pécresse vous y
croyez toujours là encore à cette
surprise ciotti oui parce que c'est une
nouvelle nouvelle campagne qui commence
même si les campagnes éclair de quelques
heures et puis le second tour n'est pas
n'est pas le premier eric ciotti lui se
concentre et veut parler aux militants
personne n'est propriétaire des voix des
adhérents c'est à eux de faire leur leur
cheminement par rapport à à la personne
qui semble plus à même de battre
emmanuel macron au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
là encore
les convictions sont très fortes les
adhérents la base des adhérents
partagent des convictions d'eric ciotti
il faut faire aussi confiance à cette
intelligence collective et je pense que
également les français mais les
adhérents et les français dans leur
ensemble vous savez les additions
d'appareils politiques lisons nous un
peu permettait dans l'expression
ras-le-bol et donc qu'ils votent avec
avec leur coeur qu'ils fassent le choix
un choix du coeur et vous verrez qu'il y
aura une surprise au second tour il y en
a déjà une aujourd'hui benjamin morel
vous êtes toujours avec nous c'est vrai
que les militantes ceux qui ont voté
aujourd'hui c'est une toute petite
partie quand même aussi peut-être des
potentiels électeurs les républicains
sont pas nécessairement les mêmes qui
voteront pour l'un ou pour l'autre le
jour de la présidentielle n'est ce pas
ah non c'est à dire que le problème
quand vous faites une primaire sur tout
particulièrement quand vous faites une
primaire entre guillemets fermés ou avec
un corps électoral restreint c'est que
vous adressez à la base de la base
vos militants de vos adhérents de aux
sympathisants cette base de la base et
pas forcément à l'image de votre
électorat existants et de votre
électorat potentiel regardez ce qui
s'est passé avec le parti socialiste
lors des dernières primaires où c'est
benoît hamon qui était plutôt très très
je dirais très à gauche dans le parti
qui l'a emporté qui ensuite vint a
permis également l'émergence d' emmanuel
macron donc là si vous voulez pour les
candidats en vue de cette primaire est
en vue demain du second tour il faut
s'adresser à une base qui est une base
très polarisée est une base très
particulière et donc le problème
évidemment c'est que par la suite les
propositions qui auront été faites dans
le cadre de cette primaire les
propositions qui ont break est fait dans
le cadre de de ce processus de sélection
il va falloir les assumer devant un
électorat plus large peut-être s'il
s'agit d'aller pécresse qui l'emportent
devant un électorat centriste cette
primaire peut être un avantage parce que
ça donne une visibilité à terme pour
certains candidats peut également
s'avérer
agir parce que c'était très juste
attention au grand écart c'est à dire
que l'on c'est à dire on s'est adressé à
nous à nos adhérents chacun avec des
convictions un projet il faudrait pas
pour autant dénaturer parce qu'on veut
faire l'ouverture il faut véritablement
rassembler notre famille politique après
rassembler notre base notre base
électorale elle va au delà de notre
famille politique il ya un phénomène qui
s'appelle eric zemmour avec des constats
qui sont qui peuvent être partagés par
eric ciotti je pense que nos solutions
peuvent répondre aux craintes de cet
électorat là également mais attention de
ne pas à gauche il est trop notre
discours pour aller pousser le centre
faisons une campagne de premier tour
d'élection présidentielle on aura
largement de quoi rassembler entre le
premier et second tours justement
l'attend la réaction d'eric zemmour qui
a forcément attiré l'attention
aujourd'hui écouter ce qui la pensée
de ce premier tour
heureux cher eric de voir nos idées si
largement partagé par les militants
aient l'air le rpr n'est pas mort un
stéphanois donné quand l hexagone et
cher eric voilà le rpr est pas mort ça
vous fait plaisir parce que il aimerait
bien s'en s'en départir aussi d'eric
zemmour eric ciotti ont entendu
d'ailleurs prendre ses distances oui
parce que l'idée encore une fois eric
ciotti et a toujours été fidèle à sa
famille politique
en fonction du résultat il soutiendra où
il se souviendra lui-même sait ce que
c'est ce que j'espère sur sur eric
zemmour quand même un constat sa
déclaration de candidature est quand
même assez révélateur de quelque chose
des constats et aucune aucune solution
concrète pour répondre aux angoisses
qu'ont les français en matière
migratoire en matière de sécurité voilà
la différence entre un polémiste et des
hommes politiques comme valérie pecresse
et comme ericsson
c'est justement on parle et voilà de ce
rapprochement peut-être de certaines un
certain point commun entre eric ciotti
et
eric zemmour al'inverse on a souvent
reproché à valérie pécresse de
ressembler un petit peu trop à emmanuel
macron qu'est ce qui pour vous justement
les différencie valérie pécresse et
emmanuel macron de l'extérieur entendre
peut-être car mip ce soir oui ballon le
il faut qu'il faudrait pas faire le
résonnement inverse de penser que les
réserves de voix de l air me serait
uniquement du côté d'eric zemmour si
dans le cas où ce sera eric ciotti qui
gênerait le congrès et inversement
uniquement du côté des manuels macron
cas où ce serait valérie pécresse quel
que soit le candidat qui gagnera à la
fin du congrès l'enjeu sera double pour
ce candidat c'est de rétablir un espace
électoral une base électorale beaucoup
plus large que celle qu'elle est
actuellement et là dessus ils ont de
levier un premier levier sur les
réformes économiques en appuyant là où
ça fait mal d'un point du lectorat macro
ni sur l'échec des manuels macro à mener
des réformes structurelles sur d'un
point de vue économique et des
différentes réformes et dans le même
temps aller récupérer l'électorat
fillonniste
qui s'est détachée de l air pour aller
vers eric zemmour actuellement ce à peu
près 20 22 % d'électeurs soit fillon qui
estime d'intentions de vote voter eric
zemmour est finalement il faudra agir
sur ces deux leviers établir et élargir
l'espace électoral en allant chercher
les électeurs où ils sont c'est à dire
chez l être cher exe moore et aussi ce
schéma gueule mâcon non c'est pas le cas
jean philippe dugoin clément justement
de votre candidate valérie pécresse qui
je le répète à qui on reproche souvent
d'être un peu trop centristes un peu
trop proche des manuels macron quand on
voit effectivement quand on cumule un
petit peu alors on se méfie plus que
jamais des sondages bien évidemment mais
les scores d'eric zemmour et score de
marine le pen c'est très très à droite
sa vie il ya moins d'un an des u15
ministre des mines le maquereau candidat
contre nous en ile de france si on les a
battus je vois pas où est la proximité
avec emmanuel macron là dessus alors sur
des postures de primaire très bien la
réalité c'est qu'il ya jamais eu le
moindre connivence ou le moins drôle il
ya quelques jours eu une femme qui a
porté un projet politique assumée
différent celui du gouvernement
comme eric ciotti comme d'ailleurs les
trois autres candidats qui ont concouru
à cette primaire au premier tour la
réalité à laquelle nous allons être
confrontés au delà de ça c'est d'arriver
véritablement à partir du 5 décembre
matin à rassembler rassembler sur un
projet de rupture à rassembler tout le
monde si nous ne parvenons pas à faire
ça le résultat on le connaît c'est les
élections européennes qui ont terminé à
moins de 10% c'est l'antithèse de ce que
nous souhaitons porter les uns comme les
autres et nous ne pourrons nous ne
pourrons arriver effectivement un
résultat positif ont travaillé ensemble
en élargissant notre base et en faisant
sur un programme et des idées claires
c'est ce qui a été défendu pendant cette
primaire qui sert de base et qui sera là
lui que portera d'aleri pécresse bien
évidemment en y associant les quatre
candidats de la primaire qui n'auront
pas
remporter sept aps une heure où de
manière à pouvoir rassembler 10 à 6 rex
yachts et il ya une primaire discussion
sera inverse mais l'objectif est qu'il
n'y ait plus qu'un candidat qui puisse
rassembler et valérie ce rang des tables
le fair benjamin morel or ce qui est
cocasse ce soir c'est que c'est vrai que
les deux finalistes
a priori toujours dans les études
d'opinion on est bien obligé d'en parler
même si on s'en méfie plus que jamais
n'était pas en mesure de l'emporter
justement face à emmanuel macron la
plupart du temps quand ils n'ont
d'ailleurs été jamais placé au second
tour seul xavier bertrand l'a l'a été
c'est vrai que
la droite peut s'inquiéter
oui la droite est dans une situation
difficile elle a pas réellement les clés
de son destin et c'est ça aujourd'hui le
vrai problème alors la comparaison avec
les élections régionales au municipal
tient peu en réalité la vème république
elle est fondée sur principe de
l'alternance et pour incarner
l'alternance pour incarner l'alternative
l'alternance en ile de france et dans
les autres ans et ben c'était par
définition pas valérie pécresse xavier
bertrand il y avait un sortant donc il y
avait déjà et bien un paul et ce pôle il
était l'heure pour les élections
présidentielles et bien le pôle est
beaucoup plus emmanuel macron il faut
apparaître comme étant l'alternative la
plus crédible à emmanuel macron sinon
bah vous a laissé passer aux européennes
vous avez une partie de lectorat et
l'eire qui votent macron parenti le
pénis mais une partie de l'électorat le
lr qui vote le pen parents team acronis
est donc cette prise en étau aujourd'hui
elle extrêmement dangereuse pour l air
aujourd'hui vous avez une base
électorale qui reste à l air qui est
généralement plutôt âgée qui a une forte
identité politique et qui est fidèle si
jamais l'air veut l'emporter eh bien
elle doit s'étendre aux dépens de l'un
de ses deux pôles voir des deux mais
surtout de l'un d'entre eux et là il ya
une stratégie qu'ils disent est d'une
certaine façon échappe à l air soit il
ya un effondrement d'eric zemmour et de
marine le pen est une possibilité
d'extension comme l'ont fait d'autres
partis en europe le vp en autriche les
tommies en grande bretagne exceptée
rassure cet espace politique soit il ya
un effondrement des manuels mâcon et une
stratégie de captation des centres est
possible mais à les capter comme vous
devez le faire valérie pécresse les
électeurs de centre droit en considérant
que ces électeurs de centre droit la
préfèrerait emmanuel macron alors qu
emmanuel macron y est en poste et qui
répond tout de même à leurs
préoccupations c'est compliqué à les
capter pour et le subtil des électeurs
qui aujourd'hui sont fidèles à marine le
pen s'est également compliquer dès lors
qu'elle apparaît comme étant l'opposante
la plus structurelle emmanuel macron se
disait menacée de peau d'un tueur du
cercle eh bien ça fragilise et l'air
depuis cinq ans alors justement sur
cette base électorale je vous propose
avant de vous faire réagir d'écouté
stanislas frigo en génération z un
proche donc d'eric zemmour écouter ce
qu'ils en pensent pourquoi ciotti est il
au second tour parce qu'il a tenu un
discours à droite le discours d'une
vraie droite la base et l'air comme nous
le disons depuis des mois est réellement
à droite cet effet le régulier vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse stanislas
rigaux oui enfin je voudrais rebondir je
suis réellement à droite en tout cas là
elle a montré par rapport à la ligne
politique d'eric ciotti je pense que
c'était son slogan il est de droite
c'est une droite à assumer maintenant
sur l'élection présidentielle par
rapport au candidat sortant emmanuel
macron sur sous la vème république
jamais aucun président sortant n'a été
élu sur un programme de continuité ça
s'est vu avec françois mitterrand et
jacques chirac a eu des périodes de
cohabitation qui leur a permis d'avoir
un nouveau souffle une nouvelle offre
politique les je pense qu emmanuel
macron fait une erreur stratégique en se
prétendant favori de l'élection
présidentielle et sans avoir ce ce
pouvoir d'auto critique sur son action
pour pouvoir proposer une nouvelle offre
une nouvelle à nouveau souffle à son
projet et donc je pense que là il ya
véritablement pour nous une opportunité
quel que soit le candidat qui sortira
d'ailleurs du congrès pour véritablement
incarner l'alternative l'alternance à
emmanuel emery blessé d'accord avec ce
diagnostic est vraiment là une
opportunité ou comme on le disait
benjamin morel c'est vrai que la lr
aujourd'hui sont en situation qui peut
de faiblesse et ne maîtrisent pas leur
destin bien sûr que les opportunités il
ya une opportunité pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord c'est le manuel macron
qu'il va devoir se réinventer pour la
campagne 2022 il doit à la fois
maintenir l'esprit des réformes de 2017
pour continuer à séduire un électorat
plutôt de centre droit et en même temps
incarné la continuité porter un bilan et
être un peu le vote utile d'une partie
de la gauche qui veut faire barrage à
des candidatures comme celle d'eric
zemmour et marine le pen qui pour lui
sont très anxiogène donc il doit réussir
à danser sur ses deux pieds à la fois
c'est du rectorat de centre-droit et en
même temps continuer à être un vote
utile pour une partie de la gauche et ça
va être compliqué pour lui de l'autre
côté il ya une difficulté structurelle à
la fois pour l'eczéma et pour marine le
pen incarné une forme d'alternance c'est
que pour l'instant dans toutes les
études d'opinion ils n'ont jamais battu
emmanuel macron et on a on s'aperçoit
quand on regarde en détail que les
variations dans les opinions de vos
d'eric zemmour de marine le pen auprès
des catégories populaires c'est qu'à peu
près 10% des lectorats qui varient pour
eric zemmour quand ils pensaient qu
ericsson aurait plus de chances de
battre marine le pen eric zemmour c'est
tellement radical y ait dans ses prises
de position et elle manque iv l'opinion
que finalement il apparaît comme plus
anxiogènes pour l'opinion que marine le
pen et 7 électoral est en train de
revenir vers marine on ne peut pas
exclure que finalement n'ayant pas
trouvé de choix pertinent pour battre
emmanuel macron entre eric zemmour et
marine le pen cet électorat là ne se
déporte pourquoi pas sur candidats aient
l'air pour faire battre manama alors
justement jean philippe dugoin clément
est ce que votre poulain je sais pas
comment on le dit au féminin valérie
pécresse va devoir se droitiser
justement pour tenter de l'emporter
franchement est de se qualifier pour le
second tour ont justement on se souvient
quand même que la même valérie pécresse
en 2019 avait claqué la porte un petit
peu des républicains en disant voilà
c'est un peu trop à droite de la ligne
de laurent wauquiez moelleux elle me
convient pas donc il va falloir faire un
petit numéro d'équilibriste
si vous me permettez je crois
sincèrement la question des papes se
droitiser sur centraide savoir ace
combat est-ce-qu'il une automaticité à
prendre des voix d'emmanuel macron
apprend des voix de marine le pen le
d'eric zemmour la question de fond pour
nos compatriotes pour les français c'est
est ce qu'on est capable de porter des
solutions et le cerf est ce qu'on est
capable d'avoir un programme aujourd'hui
au fond on assiste à quoi il ya une
extrême droite qui fait des constats qui
fait des diagnostics mais qui est
incapable portée des solutions et il ya
un gouvernement en place qui était là
depuis quatre ans et demi et qui n'a
rien fait a été incapable de faire est
le sujet qui est basse forte pour nous
quel que soit le candidat qui soit
désigné le 4 décembre hormis la question
de rassembler parce que la division tu
quoi qu'il se passe ça va être d'être
crédible sur le fait de pouvoir faire
est de pouvoir apporter des solutions et
ça c'est quelque chose qui se fait sur
la base d'un programme d'un programme de
rupture sur des thématiques fortes qui
sont d'économies qui sont pouvoir
d'achat qui sont la sécurité qui sont
l'éducation et c'est sur cela on gagnera
ou qu on échouera mais ça ne sera pas
sur des positionnements politiques sur
des jeux d'estrade ou en pensant qui ait
une automaticité parce qu'on s'appelle
eric ciotti ou valérie pécresse de
pouvoir rassembler de manière quasiment
automatique un peu plus sur tel ou tel
champ des lecteurs les français veulent
des solutions ils veulent des réalités
vol de l'acsi stéphane heureux de lier
le mot de la fin sur votre candidat perd
samedi est ce qu il
va peut-être est amené à rejoindre eric
zemmour on se souvient thème qu'il a
aujourd'hui qu'il voterait eric zemmour
contre emmanuel macron n'a évidemment
pas dit valérie pécresse en précisant
que c'est pas un scénario sur lequel il
envisage de poser mon tour non
clairement il a toujours toujours dit il
est fidèle à sa famille politique depuis
41 ans forcément si dorénavant d'aleri
pécresse sortait en tête du conseil
gagner ce congrès il soutiendrait
valérie pécresse a fait aucun doute est
il là il n'ad'ailleurs reformuler ce
soir tout simplement pour dire que sa
famille politique et ce qu'il compte
pour lui le plus est que comme l'a dit
très justement monologue il ya place à
la division
nous sommes dans un carrefour on a une
ligne de crête pour gagner et c'est
grâce à ce rassemblement qu'on va
pouvoir faire dès le début 4 au soir dé
8,5 au matin que les français vont
pouvoir avoir une expérience porter une
espérance c'est notre responsabilité par
rapport à l'avenir la france
effectivement vous n'avez pas être
ennemis longtemps puisque c'est samedi
le second tour mais on est
merci en tout cas à tous les quatre ans
m glissez sur ce plateau stéphane le
rudulier jean philippe dugoin clément et
benjamin morel merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct avec nous